PROFESSOR: So we'll do the
relativistic corrections.
And all the corrections
that I'll do today,
I'll skip the easy but sometimes
a little tedious algebra.
It's not very tedious.
Nothing that is pages
and pages of algebra.
It's lines of algebra.
But why would I
do it in lecture?
No point for that.
So let's see what we can do.
This is the
relativistic correction,
the minus p squared.
So could we write this for
the relativistic correction?
We're going to do first order
correction, relativistic,
of the levels n l ml.
Let's put a question mark.
Minus 1 over 8 m cubed c squared
psi n l ml p to the fourth.
Now recall that p to the
fourth, the way it was given,
is really p squared
times p squared.
You have four things that
have to be multiplied.
So it's not px to the fourth
plus py to the fourth plus
pz to the fourth is px
squared plus py squared
plus pz squared, all
squared, just in case
there's an ambiguity.
That seems reasonable.
The first order
corrections should
be found by taking the
states and finding this.
But there is a
big question mark.
And this kind of
question is going
to come up every time you
think about these things.
This formula, where
I said the shift
of the energy of this state
is that state evaluated here,
applies for nondegenerate
perturbation theory.
And if the hydrogen
atom is anything,
it's a system with a
lot of degeneracies.
So why can I use that,
or can I use that?
We have the hydrogen atom.
I just deleted it here.
So here, if you have n,
for degeneracies you fix n.
For degeneracies, you
fix some value of n.
And now you have the
degeneracies between
the various l's, for each
l between the various m's.
A gigantic amount of degeneracy.
Who allows me to do that?
I'm supposed to take that
level three has nine states,
remember?
n square states.
Well, we should do a 9 by 9
matrix here and calculate this.
Nine sounds awful.
We don't want to do
that so we better think.
So this is the situation
you find yourself.
Technically speaking,
this is a problem
in the degenerate
perturbation theory.
We should do that.
And you better think about
this every time you face this
problem because sometimes you
can get away without doing
the degenerate analysis,
but sometimes you can't.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It's like
rotationally symmetric.
So you can mix terms with
different [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: OK.
So you're saying, basically,
that this thing in this basis--
so we have nine states here.
n equal 3.
In these nine states,
it doesn't mix them.
So this is diagonal here.
And what one is
claiming by doing
that is that this
is a good basis,
that delta H is
already diagonal there.
And don't worry, we can do it.
In fact, that is true.
And the argument goes like that.
We know that p to the
fourth, the perturbation,
commutes with l squared.
We'll discuss it a little more.
And p to the fourth
commutes with lz as well.
So these are two claims.
Very important claims.
Remember, we had a
remark that I told you
few times few lectures ago.
Very important.
If you have a
Hermitian operator that
commutes with your
perturbation for which
the states of your
bases are eigenstates
with different eigenvalues,
then the basis is good.
So here it is.
l squared commutes
with p to the fourth.
Why?
Because, in fact, p
to the fourth commutes
with any angular momentum
because p to the fourth
is p squared times p squared.
And p squared is
rotational invariant.
p squared commutes with any l.
If that's not
obvious intuitively,
which it should become
something you trust--
this is rotational invariant.
p squared dot product doesn't
depend on rotation.
If you have a p and you square
it or you have a rotated p
and you square
it, it's the same.
So p to the fourth
commutes with any component
of angular momentum.
So these two are written
like great facts,
but the basic fact is that
p squared with any li is 0.
And all this follows from here.
But this is a
Hermitian operator.
This is a Hermitian operator.
And the various states,
when you have fixed n,
you can have different l's.
But when you have
different l's, there
are different
eigenvalues of l squared.
So in those cases, the
matrix element will vanish.
When you have the same l's
but different m's, these
are different eigenvalues of lz.
So the matrix element
should also vanish.
So this establishes rigorously
that that perturbation,
p to the fourth, is
diagonal in that subspace.
So the subspace relevant
here is this whole thing.
And in this subspace,
it's completely diagonal.
Good.
So generally, this kind of point
is not emphasized too much.
But it's, in fact, the most
important and more interesting
and more difficult point
in this calculations.
We'll have one more
thing to say about this.
But let's continue with this.
I'll say the following.
We use the Hermiticity
of p squared
to move one p squared
to the other side.
So Enl ml 1 is equal to
minus 1 over 8m cubed
c squared p squared psi
nlm p squared psi nml--
nlm.
OK.
We move this p to the fourth.
It was p squared
times p squared.
One p squared is Hermitian.
We move it here.
And then, instead of calculating
a billion derivatives here,
you use the fact that p squared
over 2m plus v of r on the wave
function is equal to the energy
of that wave function that
depends on n times
the wave function.
These are eigenstates.
So p squared-- we don't
want to take derivatives,
and those expectation values can
be replaced by a simpler thing.
P squared on psi is just
2m En minus v of r psi.
So Enlm 1 is equal to minus
1 over 8m cubed c squared.
Here we have, well, the m's.
Two m's are out, so we'll
put a 2 and an mc squared.
Yep.
En minus v of r psi En
minus v of r psi nlm nlm.
OK.
We got it to the point
where I think you can all
agree this is doable.
Why?
Because, again, this
term is Hermitian,
so you can put it
to the other side.
And you'll have terms in which
you compute the expectation
value on this
state of E squared.
E squared is a number, so
it goes out, times 1, easy.
En cross terms with vr
is the expectation of v
of r in this state,
is the expectation
of 1 over r in a state.
That's easy.
It comes from the
Virial theorem.
Then you'll have the expectation
of v squared in a state,
and that's the expectation of
1 over r squared in a state.
You've also done it.
So yes, getting all together,
getting the factors right
would take you 15 minutes
or 20 minutes or whatever.
But the answer is already clear.
So let's write the answer.
And the answer is that
Enl ml 1 relativistic is
minus 1/8 alpha to the fourth.
That's our very
recognizable factor.
mc squared 4n over
l plus 1/2 minus 3.
Now, fine structure
is something all of us
must do at least
once in our life.
So I do encourage you to
read the notes carefully
and just do it.
Just become familiar with it.
It's a very nice subject,
and it's something
you should understand.
So here, again, I have to
do a comment about basis,
and those comments keep
coming because it's
an important subject.
And I want to emphasize it.
So what is the reason?
The reason I wanted to comment
is because in a second,
I'm going to do the
spin orbit term.
And in that case, I would like
to work with a coupled basis.
Here, I'm working with
the uncoupled basis.
And really, this thing
is the expectation value
of Hl relativistic in nl ml ms
nl ml ms. This is really that.
I wrote psi nl ml, so you should
trust the first three labels.
And ms goes for the ride.
It's this spin.
The operator you're putting
here, delta H relativistic,
has nothing to do with spin.
Could not change the
spin of the states.
This has to be diagonal in spin.
So this number you've
computed is nothing else
than this overlap in
the uncoupled basis.
So this calculation was
uncoupled basis matrix element.
And we saw that it's diagonal.
In fact, this whole
thing is nothing
but the function of n and l.
n and l.
And independent
of ml and ms. OK.
That's what we've calculated.
So here is the question.
We could consider this in
the coupled bases nlj mj.
nlj mj.
And the question is, do I
have to recalculate this
in the coupled basis or not?
And here is an argument that I
don't have to recalculate it.
So I'm going to claim that
this is really equal to that.
Just the same.
It's the kind of thing that
makes you a little uneasy,
but bear with me.
Why should it be the same?
Think of this as fixed
n and l because this
depends on n and l.
If we have the
hydrogen atom here,
you'd take one of these
elements, one of these states--
this is a fixed n, fixed l.
And we're looking
at fixed n, fixed l.
Yes.
There are lots of states here
that have different ml and ms.
But the answer doesn't depend
on ml and ms. In this basis,
we are also looking at that
subspace, that multiplet,
nl fixed.
And they have reorganized
the states with j and mj.
In fact, with two values of
j and several values of mj.
But at the end of the
day, the coupled basis
is another way to describe
these states coming
from tensoring the l
multiplet with a spin 1/2.
So it gives you two multiplets,
but they are the same states.
So the fact that
every state here
is some linear combination
of states in the uncoupled
bases with different values of
ml and ms that add up to mj.
But this answer doesn't
depend on ml and ms.
So whatever linear
combination you need,
it doesn't change because
the answer doesn't
depend on ml and ms. So this
must be the same as that.
I'll give another argument.
Maybe a little more abstract,
but clearer perhaps.
Think of this.
So this can be--
in the notes, I explain that by
changing basis and explaining
why exactly
everything works out.
But there is no need
for that argument
if you think a little
more abstractly.
Think of this subspace.
Because with fixed n and
l, we have this subspace.
In this subspace,
the uncoupled basis
makes the perturbation diagonal.
But more than diagonal, it makes
the perturbation proportional
to the unit matrix, because
every eigenvalue is the same.
Because in this subspace,
n and l is fixed.
And yes, m and ms
change, but the answer
doesn't depend on that.
So this matrix, delta
H, in this subspace
is proportional to
the unit matrix.
And when a matrix is
proportional to the unit
matrix, it is
matrix in any orthogonal basis.
A unit matrix
doesn't get rotated.
So it should be a unit
matrix here as well,
and it should be
the same matrix.
So this is the same pair.